can someone anyone give me one
suggestion in terms of the method how
would you work out the volume any takers
any takers no right now I saw people who
had at least an idea anyone ask the
company that's possible but boring ok we
are mathematicians we want to work this
out ourselves right and not to mention
if we ask the company well clearly
someone to accompany Oh to work it out
right so they had to do it somehow as
well what else could we do say that
again ok if you did not have written
down or typed up a wet ever volume of a
cylinder then you should now can I just
have one of the school's back young
beyond yeah that one don't think ok yeah
you have a look and I think it's fair
enough you know you look at it and
immediately like well it's rock mystical
a new cool ok I will point out it's kind
of a bit of a I'm problem with calling
mrs. Mellon art which is that what is a
big hole in the middle but guess what
the hole is also a son right so I
suppose you could say over here on the
right-hand side I suppose you could say
volume of the big cylinder like the
whole thing and then you could just
subtract the volume of the little one
rishabh where you reckon question isn't
volume usually life water including
three they're not as well ah so that's a
great question rishabh here's where
we're talking about something which i'm
not sure if your way up to in your
syllabus program in the moment but this
is our we distinguish between volume and
capacity and by the way one of ways you
can know that which ones which is the
word capacity it literally tells you
what it is because just look at the word
capacity means how much is it capable of
holding how much can you put in there
and it's good fit right whereas volume
is about how much space it takes up not
necessarily how much you keep putting
this a good question ok all right so
here's flood methods hands up who had
that as their method is update yep okay
fantastic that's good now I think that's
a good first way to go
petitions are always searching for
multiple ways to solve problems right so
I don't look at this I see a big problem
with this which is a that even though
it's roughly cylindrical can you just
have a look at this surface here
remember this surface along that you saw
around the edges is that flat it's not
is it right so there's one problem it's
cylinder like but it's not actually a
cylinder okay not a suggestion ah that's
another issue even though this outside
is just bumpy that's not the only
problem right because if you could like
slice it across right like just cut it
right down the middle okay you wouldn't
expect to see like a solid block with um
with no holes would you write in fact
when you take that where you call that a
cross-section wouldn't you what it
looked like there'd be lots of um
wouldn't there be lots of little dots
for every time you all the hundreds of
times you cut the filament which I
assume means there's like dat right hmm
a bit of a problem right so this is a
worthy way of getting an idea but I'd
like a more accurate way it's just in
Genesis war so you could take this thing
you could submerge it right and then see
how much water is moved out of the way
that's a great tourney in fact we've got
method one which was armed cylinders
method 2 is by displacing water which by
the way was how Archimedes did a lot of
his experimentations and how we get a
lot of our formula two volumes of these
cones etc well yeah ah ah ok hold on a
second now this this third method this
is actually what I'm going to pursue
then I want us all to do okay this third
method is just to think about the
filament the whole thing if you unwound
all how many meters again all 400 meters
if you stretched out the whole thing so
it was straight what shape is that it's
not cylindrical anymore well not this
kind of political it's one really really
long thin cylinder do you agree because
it's rare
ok so I'm what's the volume of a
cylinder again pi r squared time h ok
let's work this out did anyone notice
what the piece of information was it was
on here but wasn't on the box did anyone
spoil it right here in case you looking
closely it says one point seven five
millimeters right one point seven five
millimeters which you had a good look oh
that's the thickness of the filament
isn't it so how are we going to use that
volume is pi times the radius well if
it's one point seven five millimeters
thick what does that make the radio yeah
half of that right half of that I'm um
I'm just going to write 1.75 / 2 1.75 is
the diameter isn't it that's the radius
what am I gonna do with radius again I'm
going to square that thing multiplied by
itself and then I x the height what's
that okay now i can write 400 here
except there's a little PDT knee issue
I've got 1.75 1.75 what millimeters and
then i wrote 400 400 what meters so i
need to decide what units i want and you
guys can pick whichever one you want do
you want to do meters or do you wanna do
millimeters I think millimeters is a
good choice you didn't have to do it
that way but what we don't want to
suggest to me why millimeters might be a
better choice in the other way yeah yeah
yeah
needed to be a decimal number and I'll
probably be a lot less hmm correct and
if I we've already got this decimal here
1.75 as meters I think this would be
0.001 25 I think maybe you go have a
look at different sizes and that's gross
I want to avoid that as much as I can so
let's change this into millimeters
you're happy with that because merely
means what's that preface meet again I
found them like millennium right so I've
heard 400 meters into four hundred
thousand millimeters okay have you got a
calculator there you go on it if someone
can reach for it yeah okay let's give
people a chance to catch up Stephen and
then we'll get a number out
okay we got a few more people got the
number yeah okay Jamie do you have it
there ready go ahead 306,000 215 you got
some decimal places 50 sorry yeah let's
accept 50 can I like an agreement not
agreement okay let's hold on let me put
both numbers next to each other what
number do you have does one six two nine
six two this sound familiar yep number
12 and I presume you've got some points
right 8.8 dot dot dot yes what about the
second number do I have agreement there
yes yeah no yeah we fix it what wonder
by the way okay alright cool so let's
fix that and put this guy in here
alright so we've got a number sounds
like it's a number we agree on this is a
volume so what units should I attached
to it cubic millimeters right so i'm
going to write m m cubed okay all right
now at this point i could say cool i
have volume okay and i also have a mass
but I sort of want to I mean I haven't
asked you what what units are
appropriate for the size of it I've said
millimeters this is a huge number though
I reckon we could convert this pretty
easily into cubic centimeters instead of
millimeters because this is enormous
okay so how many cubic millimeters are
there in a cubic centimeter one
centimeter cubed equals how many cubic
millimeters hmm I heard a number do
people agree with a thousand yes how can
you be sure how do you know it's not a
hundred or 10,000 how can you be sure
it's a thousand because it's right
because I got cold so what else could we
do I'm sure
and there to get 1 1 centimeter equals
10 millimeters very good and therefore
and you yeah fantastic can you see can
you see it right here right if you go
see you to hear your cubing everything
right YouTube the centimeters you also
cute the one so over here your cubanelle
ms but you also cube the 10 which as was
suggested earlier is about it ok so
therefore i can write this as 962 point
let's just go one centimeters cube
that's to one decimal place you're happy
with that now that pause and have a look
back at this thing every time you
calculate something every time you
measure something you should always do a
sense check that's saying 962 cubic
centimeters does that sound about right
yeah one of those you know I think it
looks all right oil as you can know is
you've got two other ways of suggesting
what the right answer is yeah in
textbooks and I got answers for stuff at
the back of the book how do they know
they're right answer in mass if you take
the same problem do it any different way
to you like you always get to say there
too if it's right that is ok so if you
want you can go ahead and you can verify
it you one ok ramas there now we can
work out density density equals okay now
remember before we said mask was in
kilograms because I'm looking at the
size of these numbers it might make
sense to convert kilograms into grams
right because you can see those numbers
there that I'm comparing here and here
they sort of been the same magnitude
that makes it like this is a thousands
and hundreds and this is also hundreds
so they're in the same ballpark okay so
density is going to be grams per cubic
centimeter is that like them grams per
cubic centimeter so those are some weird
numbers I'm going expect you to go to
your calculator and chuck this year
there's the whoops wrong one there's the
number of grams per the number of cubic
centimeters right so that's going to be
gram
per centimeter cubed can we get a
decimal out of that maybe a couple of
decimal places would be nice what do you
guys see it's got to be one point
something right 1.14 that's cool I
reckon that's close enough okay there
you go so now we know the identity of
that what does it mean is that event a
dancing or are not very density okay and
this is where we're going to do some
exploring us so for the rest of this
lesson I said I have some materials I
have some I have some scales we have to
unfortunately okay so here's are we
going to need to do we're going to work
out some moldings okay and these are all
pretty read looking shape okay but you
can still work out the bowling of this
thing in the same way that we did just
well what kind of shape would you
compare to don't tell me do you think
about yourself right what shape would
you competitive you work it out okay
workout volume workouts volume and then
come and work out what's message and
tell me what are these things in terms
of their densities